so I hope you are ready with energy for
the talk okay but if you want a nap
that's fine I don't have a problem with
that so we are going to talk about web
performance okay so I will start
presenting myself really quickly okay
Maximillian is my name max is fine I'm
further on Twitter I'm a mobile web
developer so I have been doing web
development seems that browser casing is
1995 so a long time ago using front-page
for example as we mentioned before I've
been traveling a lot for doing
consulting training in 66 countries this
is my first time here in Serbia
so I'm also been doing training for a
lot of companies and consulting and you
can find content and trainings from me
on different providers such as LinkedIn
learning people is known as Linda or
Safari I have also a couple of books
okay there is a kind of a trick there so
because we have original books these are
the original books and those are
translations on languages that I don't
understand so the last two books are
basically on the topic that we will be
covering the next 35 minutes probably 34
now so performance okay web performance
how many of you are currently creating
websites or web apps okay perfect and
how many of you are creating fast web
sites okay only 10% and there are a
couple of okay let's see we are going to
talk about that and how you can hack the
web performance how we can push that
even further that's the whole idea of
this talk so I have two goals for this
talk the first one is to show you a new
tricks that you can start applying in
your own websites or web apps prism and
the other one is to make you feel bad
okay about what you're doing right now
so let's start with that so um I know
that you know that your users aren't
currently not happy and probably you're
losing money okay you or your customers
or your clients are losing money why
because
of the performance or because the web is
a slow your website is a slow and sorry
to tell you that so some quick
information about this half a second
delay its increasing use of frustration
by 26% okay that's a lot half a second
delay it's reducing Google's traffic and
that's money for Google okay in terms of
add for example 100 milliseconds only
delay will decrease amazon's sales by 1%
these are all information ok so there
are a lot of information data that you
can get on this problem and i'm pretty
sure that you know that today we are not
talking about page load as a metric
there are new metrics of their user
centric not about like javascript
metrics but about from a user's point of
view and we have first meaningful pain
that is when something meaningful
appears on the page there is not just a
line or a background color so something
that the users user's brain is currently
parsing the then we have first
interactive because it's not just you
see something on the screen we should be
able to interact with that
like for example scrolling or touching
so sometimes you see a page but it's not
working okay and visually complete is
finally when you are seen the actual
content that it's not page low and I'm
sure that you're creating your own
custom metrics because that's something
that it's really important so what is
important for your users what are you
expecting your users to do on your
website on your web app and then you
measure that and so I know you know that
performance is important and we don't
need to chance the metrics we need goals
because if how fast is fast probably you
say oh my website is slowly in 15
seconds really fast right well not
really so we need to set our goals
currently the goals in the market are
around this first meaningful pain should
be between one and three seconds so the
user is typing a URL or clicking on a
link and after maximum three seconds it
should be seeing something meaningful on
the page and that means when not on your
computer and Wi-Fi that means on any
context including
let's say a low-end device with a 3G
connection slow 3G connection first
interactive has like one more second to
make that country interactive so 2 2 to
4 seconds so now you need to think about
this and see how how close are you to
these goals today so I know that you're
already doing a lot of stuff like
optimizing the network transfer such as
for example enabling sheep on text-based
files on your server you're currently
working with TLS and HTTP 2 you are
using CSS appetizer
okay so we're here in Serbia appetizer
is like a big play but typically the
appetizer should be small right so CSS
should be as small and you should start
with that so the CSS should be the first
thing that you're going to deliver to
the browser because CSS will block
rendering just small and as an appetizer
and JavaScript as dessert at the end
okay we need to defer JavaScript as much
as possible so javascript is your
baclava
basically so you are already optimizing
images you're already creating a great
image with with PNG or jpg you're
optimizing that you have an HTTP cache
policy you are currently using service
workers right everyone is using service
workers right No
so you should avoid the red X that is
when you go to a website and that
website says now we know you know what
no no it's not here you need to go there
and you go there it says no it's not
here you need to go there so for example
you type a URL and then first you go to
HTTPS which is fine but when you get
there it says oh your mobile phone no
need to go to MDOT and then you go to m
dot and it says oh you want a home page
in each you go to m dot slash home page
so all those redirects are basically
wasting time so you're not doing that I
already know this is basic web
performance techniques that you're all
doing that stuff what's the problem the
problem is even with all those
techniques the average time to load a
mobile
in beige today is 22 seconds it's really
far away from our goals okay so it's
really far away so and this is from
Google by the way so if a page is taking
more than three seconds to load more
than half of the user will start leaving
that page at that time so you're losing
users
you're losing conversion you are losing
money because you're not doing web
performance for the sake of web
performance has to to measure with the
with with your wizard clock we are doing
this because of conversion okay we want
conversion in our websites so that's why
we're doing web performance and one of
the problems is that we have been always
underestimated in mobile okay since the
beginning so for example today you can
say that it's iOS and Android but from a
web point of view if it's Safari and
chrome only so the answer is no so if
you if you have tested your website on
on mobile browsers it shouldn't be just
iOS with Safari and Chrome Android with
Chrome there are a lot of browsers out
there samsung engine the browser UC
Browser Opera Mini Chrome on iOS that is
not actually Chrome so these browsers
are currently having like good market
share so more than 3% and that means
millions of users that are currently
using those browsers and also we have
Facebook that now has a name Facebook
mobile browser what I'm saying is when
you're the user is browsing on face when
clicking on a link by default that link
is not being browsed in the browser but
inside an in a browser that in a browser
is using a different enzyme both on iOS
and Android so have a have you ever
tried your website there how it looks i
how we work in terms of performance is
it the same as Safari or Chrome it's not
so and it's a lot of a lot of users are
currently on that situation and also
when we are talking about the mobile web
is more today more than half of our
users on some situations it can be 70
and 80% of your users on mobile browsers
we are typically using cellular networks
and I know that you're thinking about
this oh we have 4G now so we shouldn't
we don't need to worry about performance
to worry but to be honest if you look at
that information that's for a couple of
months ago so less than 30 percent of
the users worldwide are currently in 4G
ok it's not so much and also sometimes
when you have your lat
you're a lucky 4G device user you're
also lucky 4G data plan user you are
also a lucky user that is currently in a
city with 4G coverage
okay so lucky users on that situation 10
percent of the time you are downgraded
to 3G okay so it happens a lot
I'm currently in 3G here I'm in roaming
I even with the iPhone 10
I mean 3G so that happens a lot that is
not just because it's instant Europe I
be in San Francisco so in the minute of
Silicon Valley
I was driving like half an hour north
and it was in 2g okay
suji in the middle of Silicon Valley so
that happens a lot with our with your
users so you need to be very careful
about that and when we are talking about
3G 4G William 5g typically your brain is
thinking about bandwidth okay so
oh it's fast 4G is faster yeah it's
faster but the problem is not the bath
way the problem is the latency so if you
think about this if you if you have at
home a 50 megabits per second connection
and you go to 100 megabits per second
are you browsing the web faster probably
not it's better for Netflix it's better
for YouTube it's ready for downloading
big files but not for browsing the web
because when you are when we are
browsing the web we're just downloading
a lot of small files and the latency if
you look there Inge is really big it can
be able to one second
that's the round-trip time that takes to
get data from the server 3G is better up
to 450 milliseconds
4G it's even better like a quarter of a
second but if you compare that with a
home the DSL connection
or an office DSL or cable connection 4G
has 10 times the latency of your home
connection so even those 4G lucky users
have big latency then that's the problem
okay so that's why we need to push web
performance even further so we need to
hack web performance so I have here a
couple of tricks okay that you're gonna
start analyzing and using in your own
websites or web app to push the web
performance further so we're going to
start talking about the first load how
we can hack the first flow so the first
time that the user is accessing your
website and it's currently being
downloaded from the server we should try
to avoid more than one round-trip this
is a very extreme case okay but it's
interesting I have I have done lot of
consulting and we did district and it's
incredible how fast you can get the
first load so the in TCP we are not
getting too deep into TCP and networking
but basically there is something known
as a slow start so even if you're not a
network engineer you know that on the
Internet basically the data is split
into packages ok TCP packets so the
promise how big are those packets okay
so if we can try to fit our website in
one packet it will get faster because it
won't need another round trip that's
basically taking the latency and there
is something known as initial congestion
window that in Linux based servers it's
around 14.6 kilobytes in fact is
kilobytes and if you don't know what the
key by byte is Google that later so 14.6
so if you can fit your first response
from the server so it's only for the
first response this in 14.6 K it will
fit in one TCP packet okay only one so
the per you say all 14 it's not too much
but we are gzip in our files so that's
around 70 K of HTML which for example
for the viewport of a mobile device
maybe okay if you can see the HTML there
see the ends are also playing with
different values of this initial
congestion window so you can see a
couple of experiments going on on this
idea so if you can deliver the ATF
content what is the IDF content above
default so above default is a content
that you see in the first scroll so if
you can fit the content for the first
scroll on a mobile device of your
website or web app in 14.6 que she
sipped you will render the content as
soon as possible and you can also embed
CSS and JavaScript details for that
first initial load only and if you still
have a space you can embed the logo and
I'm talking about embedding know an IMG
tile with a source logo jpg or logo.png
I'm talking about using basics before
and and data URI because we want embed
that in one HTML response another thing
that you can do now to increase web
performance is to avoid the HTTP to
HTTPS redirection so we you should know
I'm pretty sure that you know that you
need to move your websites to HTTPS so
it's a mandatory today every website
should be in TLS or HTTPS the problem is
that when the user is typing the URL is
not typing HTTP colon forward slash
forward slash so and the browser is
going to HTTP by default so we have a
ready rake there that can take around
300 to 500 milliseconds and we have a
tiny budget and maybe half a second is a
lot so we want to avoid that the
solution is something known as HSTs and
it's a top kind of a protocol that
you're going to add in your in your HTTP
header and you're going to say on that
first access to http hey browser you
know what my website from now on it's
will be always in HTTP so a stop go into
HTTP by default okay so next time the
user will go directly to HTTPS and we
are going to save after
half a second and also when you have
this you can go and opt-in into that
website and then a browser such as
Chrome Safari Firefox and elvish are
taking the list as a widely spring
loaded in the browser so a new user will
type your URL and if you're in that wide
list it will go directly to HTTPS
avoiding one redirect okay so after the
first load was other after the first
response was sent to the juda browser we
need to hack the data transfer okay so
okay how can we send the data even
faster over over that network over the
wireless network so first I want to talk
about something known as quick okay
there is no type of error that's the
name quick without okay it's an
experimental protocol to provide an HTTP
tube based API over UDP and not TCP in
fact if you are using Chrome and you are
browsing Google website can be Gmail
Google comm Google Drive you're
currently browsing the web using quick
okay
so quick will reduce latency a lot
because it's not using TCP if using UDP
but it's it's compatible with HTTP 2 so
basically it's compatible with all your
current let's say websites and
architecture it has something called
zero Artie Artie T so round-trip time
connection establishment so you can
analyze that later but it means that
when the user is coming back to your
website it will have zero round-trip
time to get that connection open okay so
it's increasing a lot in fact for the
Google search page is increasing the
performance by three percent a YouTube
has reduced 30 percent of buffering
thanks to using quick Facebook has a
similar protocol for their app it's
improving performance by two percent and
according to Google three quarters of
every request on the web can be faster
if you will use quick instead
of normal HD be too quick is
experimental but it's currently
available in Chrome and it's there are
some works and other browsers as well
and of course you need to add something
on your server so you can serve your
website using quick into the browser is
compatible with quick okay cool
so some flea repeat with me some flea so
this is a new algorithm for ship that
will encode your ships compressing more
okay it can save up to 8 percent of the
data transfer so the same HTML when you
send that over the wire or the wireless
channel it will occupy less bytes okay
so the problem is that it's 80 times
slower so it consumes 80 times more CPU
for compressing not for decompressing
but because it's cheap days it works
with ie6 it works with every browser so
you can start applying this on your
server and then you will save data
transfers so your website will appear
faster on users devices and you will
save data transfer in the meantime if we
want to push this even further there is
another protocol known as broadly by the
way we are talking about a German names
here in this case you can say up to 25%
compared to ship but it's not gzip
compatible so you need a browser
compatible with broadly and so you can
check the encoding header by the way
there are a couple of broadly compatible
browsers of today including Chrome
including some versions of Safari and
Firefox so you need to check the
encoding header and then send the
broadly version for LinkedIn for example
they have saved 4% in lowly time so if
you take 4% from here 3% from here 2%
from here again because we have a tiny
budget you can actually save a lot of
time and you can actually be closer to
your performance goals
so Facebook has saved you CSS okay and
also a serving JavaScript files using
broadly and by the way will broadly
remember that we mentioned the 14.6 k
threshold for the initial response if we
are using broadly we can say we can
store up to 80 85 kilobytes of HTML on
on one TCP packet readable streams this
is also interesting is coming right now
on some browsers it will let you process
the data as soon as alright so let me
give you a quick example it's typically
today if you have a web app it can be a
react application it can be a angular
application or view or whatever a
vanilla is so you are downloading a JSON
file you are parsing the JSON file
client-side and you're rendering
something on the HTML okay that's
basically the idea but let's say you're
downloading one hand real items no
client CDs whatever you're downloading
so you're starting parsing that JSON
file only when you have the 100 you
cannot like take a chunk of the JSON as
soon as he's arriving from the network
you're receiving the file using Ajax or
the fetch API you are using you're
receiving the file when you have the
total file so what if we can start
receiving from the network layer pcs
chunks of the response and start
analyzing each chunk and I start
rendering as soon as it's at one part of
the JSON is available so that API is
call readable streams is available on
some browsers and you can start playing
with it and he can save on pain metrics
when you are doing this kind of
client-side rendered solution so that's
for the initial page and also for
sending device from the server to the
client what about loading the rest of
the resources images videos web fonts
style sheets and JavaScript files
so we have new modern cache control
systems that you can start using for
example if how many of you are react or
angular developers let's see okay quite
like 20 percent so you're probably using
the CL is probably uh no or webpack at
least so DC lies when you're compiling
your your apps are creating file names
with hash for your resources for example
your your style.css file it's not a size
dot CSS size dot hash like xh 0 to 4 dot
CSS and every time you change that file
the name changes so now we have a way to
for the browser to say you know what
instead of doing conditional request we
know for sure that that file will never
change because if we are changing the
CSS file react or angular CLI will
change the file name so we know for sure
that is not going to change so we ask
the browser hey browser if you have a
cached version of that file use it
because I will never change it on the
server and that's known as cache control
immutable ok that is currently available
on those browsers in chrome it's kind of
great because chrome is not supporting
it yet but it has like a similar
intelligent solution that is finally
getting to the same result and also
there is a common new pattern that is
available mostly with service workers
not sure how many of you have played
with service workers let's see ok quite
a few only one percent so we'll change
that but there is a new pattern there
known as a stale war evaluate like you
always serve the file from the cache ok
so from the local cache so you serve the
file really quickly it's in my local
cache so here you have it but it might
be outdated because maybe on the server
you have a new version so then the
browser is updating that in the
background so the next time you request
that resource it will be updated that's
known as a stale word revalidate
you have play with service workers it's
a common design pattern and now that
design pattern is coming to browsers so
you can specify that you want to use
that behavior stage where we validate
and the browser will do that for you it
will give you the cached version when
you're actually I mean IMG tag and just
a script tag it will take it from the
cache but in the background it will go
and update the resource for the next
time okay
warming up engines so when the browser
is trying to download resources we can
try to warm up the energize and help the
browser to start some processes as soon
as possible
for example DNS queries when you are
downloading files from a different
domain for a different origin it a DNS
query is needed so you can like change
resolve the name to an IP address and
that might tape up to 200 milliseconds
and that's a lot because we have a tiny
budget so and also connecting to TCP and
the TLS connection can be another 200
milliseconds when you are going into
another server so we can announce
DNS queries as soon as possible at the
top of your HTML you can add a link with
a rel DNS prefetch and you're announcing
the browser here browser
later I will request a file from that
server so you can start the DNS right
now before hands also you can use pre
connect in this case it's not just the
knee and ask worried
it's also you're going to create the TLS
and TCP connection to that server okay
even if the browser doesn't know that
you will need a resource from that
server and on both you can use an HTTP
header instead of HTML so when you are
answering with your HTML you're going to
say hey browser you know what later this
HTML will need these than this domain so
start the connection right now to bundle
are not you bundle so what is this so
this is a typical question that I
received in terms of JavaScript and CSS
so typically you have 10
51 hand with CSS file and Charles can
fight I've seen that
so should we create it like one big
bundle or should we create a lot of
script tags and link tags for different
clients on HTTP to bundling seems like
an oddly pattern however it's not
bonding is still a good idea in fact
this is a tweet from Paul Irish saying
that from the chrome team saying that
today
Bandon is still the best possible idea
so create one big javascript file one
big CSS file but big however here I'm
talking about only the necessary content
for rendering initial rendering not the
whole website or page so we need Co
split in first and then for the initial
render in only one file okay so that's
the idea so don't create a fine megabyte
javascript file because that's not idea
it should be really small only for the
important part and then you defer and
download the rest so web fonts web fonts
are nice okay we can change the default
fonts that we are using websites but we
have a problem that Brown you have seen
that the flash on of unstyled text what
is this you access a website you see the
logo you see the backgrounds and no text
and text on the web was always
non-blocking
text was just text it was there before
automatically we don't need to wait but
now when we're using web fonts we are
waiting for the font and that's a
problem so now you haven't CSS a way to
define how do you want to load this with
phone display so look for phone display
so you can specify the algorithm so you
can create a more performant solution
for this and finally for resource
loading we have pre loading so pre
loading is even like a better way of the
pre of prefetching or the DNS prefetch
or the pre connect so it's we are
pushing it even further we can help the
browser priority
time's the most important resources for
example the font file okay so you use a
link rel preload and you're going to say
this isn't a stylesheet this is a web
phone this is a script tag and you will
need it later but I start downloading
now so we can help the browser to
download the most important files a
sooner with more priority okay and that
will save a lot of time for your metrics
you can also of course use an HTTP
response header in instead of a link
time as well
hacking images so we know that the
picture is worth a thousand words the
problem is that if it loads okay so we
need to load pictures so first you need
to embrace responsive images okay that
means you need to deliver not one image
not three versions of the image okay
because today a lot of traffic is coming
from images and you can improve a lot
your metrics if you create end versions
that is the version that is exactly the
one that is needed for that particular
user also it's time to replace normal
standard JPEG and PNG files
remember softly the one I mentioned
before for gzip the same algorithm works
over deflate and PNG are used in deflate
meaning that you can compress your PNG
files 20% more using this new algorithm
ok and it works everywhere because they
filled PNG and also we have a JPEG
version of this it's called gastly
another German name that will lay Ewing
like compress your JPEG files even more
without reducing quality so these are
new compression algorithm that are open
source are available right now so you
can start helping your users with
performance ok so a star working with
that and the last thing that I have for
you has to do with how to hack user
experience so with something known as
reactive web performance so
I pretty sure that if you are Netflix
users you have seen this in action from
an ethical point of view it's difficult
to see Netflix with a buffering system
typically nothing is changing the
quality of the streaming as soon as the
pathway is changing ok this is a similar
idea web for the web so we can know
about the context today using
client-side performance api's network
information api device memory client
hints api's so basically you can detect
the current connection of the user the
banth with the latency you can attack
the current available memory so you can
know if it's a feature phone if it's the
latest Android device and make a
decision about that because maybe you
have the latest Android device the
latest iPhone device but you are in to
Jean roaming so it doesn't make any
sense to send a very super high quality
ultra resolution to that device because
it will never arrive and that's a bad
experience we need to keep the the user
the consistency and the consistent
experience so for example if you're in
roaming done sand web phones we can
change the serviceworkers cache policy
so if we are into G we can say ok let's
go first to the cached version because
it will be slow and we want to improve
users experience we can reduce the
amount of loaded data and maybe you can
send a low resolution image not matter
the device picks a radio or the
resolution ok you might have a 4k screen
but if if you have a very slow Network
doesn't make any sense to send that
picture you can just then send a low
resolution image so you're feeling bad
now but what you're doing yeah no yes so
performance is top priority
ok if you want to succeed on the web on
web apps is top rated Lee because it was
proven that it has to do with conversion
it will give you conversion so you need
to push it even more you need to start
you need to learn how to measure with
the new metrics and it's a really
worthwhile effort so ok so please please
take
take time and budget to improve the
performance of your website okay please
please do it so that's nice okay by the
way
make it fast please so that's all for me
so thank you and see you later because I
have another talk on progressive web
apps on the other room okay thanks
[Applause]